Please welcome, the amazing, hilarious, my old friend,
Seth Meyers.
(audience applauds and upbeat music)
Hello everybody, thank you for having me.
How old do you think we were when we first met
on like SNL.
I think you were probably 25 and I was like 13.
No, I'm kidding.
No, I mean, you must have, well, so I was 27
when I started the show.
So I bet you were there the first few years, so 28, 29.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, it's crazy.
It's been a really long time.
I mean, I remember us being at like
after parties, you know, like young, carefree.
Yeah, I get hung over thinking about those parties.
I stopped drinking.
Yeah.
I had such a good time
at those after parties, they were so fun.
Yes.
Okay, well, we were talking
upstairs about the fact that you just had Letterman
celebrating 40 years of Late Night.
Yes.
I mean, how was that?
You know, I love him.
Yes,
it was a lovely conversation.
And it did, it was the 40th anniversary of
the Late Night Franchise.
And of course it wouldn't be around if it wasn't for him.
So it was a cool thing to do.
I mean, that was where I developed.
That was where I developed my crush for him
was on Late Night, was on your beloved franchise.
I thought he was so hot.
I know, you know, fingers crossed,
there's someone out there who's developing a crush on me
based on Late Night.
Possible, right?
Seth, I remember from SNL, when we were all young,
everyone always had crushes on you.
Oh, thank you so much,
that's what I'll tell my kids tonight.
Yes you should.
And you know what,
mommy, isn't the only one
Women have been hot for me forever.
Anyway, where's your duck?
You were such a catch and you married a beautiful woman
and you fell madly in love.
I did a very good job.
She's a real catch and we're making good kids,
and I think that's how, you know, there she is.
And that's a hat she wears every day.
Can I ask, like when you first met her,
did you know, was it a love at first sight?
Was it a friendship first?
So, it's a true story.
You know, we met at Chris Kattan's wedding.
You remember Chris Kattan?
I just saw Chris at Jimmy's, at Fallon's.
Oh, yeah, there you go, he was just there
And he, and I have a saying called rooftops
because he and I both got drunk with a bunch of friends
and jumped off rooftops together.
So that's like...
I think it's really good you stopped drinking.
Rooftops.
Every time we see each other, rooftops.
In all fairness, it was into pools.
It was into pools.
I probably should have added that.
Yeah, that's a very good thing to add.
So you're at Kattan's wedding.
Yeah, but this is a true story, we met the first night,
you know, Friday rehearsal dinner night.
And then we sat next to each other at the wedding,
and people, we were such a immediate fit,
that people were asking us, like,
how long have you guys been together?
And we were like, oh, we met yesterday, so...
That's what I see,
it's like, you guys look like two human puzzle pieces.
Well, or as Rachel Dratch said that day,
'cause she was at the wedding.
She goes, oh my God, you look like brother and sister.
I'm like, don't say that.
(upbeat music)